good afternoon today the health district is
going
to inform the public about
how the vaccination campaign is developing
in our community
and what are the next steps
that we are going to take
first I would like to
inform you that so far we
have vaccinated more than  20 29 thousand people
here in the county with both
the fighter vaccine and the
modern vaccine these first doses have been
administered to health workers
either in the hospitals here in the
counties as well as
health workers who
work in  the outpatient system, that is,
medical offices or therapy areas and
others and other health centers
at this time what we are planning
to start
offering the vaccine to other groups starting tomorrow in
this case we are going to start offering the
vaccine to  County residents
who are
over 70 years of age and
also what are called essential workers in the state plan
Within that group of
special workers we are going to
offer the vaccine to the first block that
appears in the priority line of
the state plan. The first block includes
education workers from both
the
[Music
] county public school system
and  The private ones and other systems that
exist here in education are also
going to be offering the vaccine to the
workers of the higher education system,
that is, what the
colleges and universities
are called, they are also going to be offering the vaccine
to the employees  those who work for
the city and the county
as well as those who work in
public transportation and those
who work in port services
and also a group that is a little more
diverse which is the group called transportation
workers.  common community of
sol de sol de sopor de apoyo which is a
very diverse group
that includes other groups then a
house of work
Social services that work in the court are requested, it is in
the legal system and charters
and other groups that will be more
defined on the website because it is a
very diffuse group, the one I just
mentioned, but hey, this will be the
groups that  We are going to start from
tomorrow also that we want to point out that
at the moment the health district
is working on this campaign with with
with with several with several collaborators such
as universities in counties and
in the cloud in the vii the density of Las
Vegas as
well  At Rose Mary University, all of the
University, we are also
working with the MC University Hospital
and with the cities of Las Vegas and people
who are already
offering vaccines to their
population and in the future withering the
same  city ​​of mesquite and voice of citi are
also going to start offering vaccine
to their residents
the other thing i wanted to tell you is that
this week starting tomorrow
thursday in april county in the center
of tasman tomorrow is going to be a
test day for this center and it's coming it's going to
be working at full capacity
in this casma center it's going to be a mega
of between 3,000 and 4,000 appointments  to
receive the vaccine in this center in
addition to that within the next two
weeks the health district is going to open
another mega center enter the
las vegas convention center this mega
center in which is going to be opened by the
district is also going to  offer between
3,000 and 4,000 doses of vaccines a
day, whether we are going to have
between two weeks, two large
vaccine centers that are going to be open to the
community, as well as centers that go, which
is like a blessing previously in
the different  cities and also for the
university of las vegas nev and all rose
man that will also offer the vaccine
and something also important that we
calculate that our weekly capacity
will be around 40 to 45 thousand
will  cribs that we are going to be able to offer to
our population, but we must bear in
mind that this capacity could
be diminished if we do not receive a
sufficient quantity of vaccines from the
state and the federal government for that
week, but our capacity will be
up to 40 45,000  weekly and if the
vaccines are received, they will all be
offered to the population. It
is also important that
people know that in order to receive this
vaccine they will have to
sign up, either to register at the different sites to
have their appointments, because what we do not
want to happen  It is that people
are
spending long hours waiting at the
evacuation center so that in the end they are
frustrated and do not receive the vaccine because
they were not registered for that day and there
were no extra vaccines for people
who were not expected to offer the
service  that day is that it is important
that you know that and also that
unfortunately we are not all going, we will not
be able to be vaccinated the same day of  the
same week and we need your support
in that you have patience
with us and wait according to dyj
and you will get the opportunity to get vaccinated
but it is important that you sign up and so that you
have the chair
I will stop here and for some
questions that you may
Hello Fermín, can you hear me if I'm listening? I
'm Fernando, hello Fermín, it's a pleasure to
greet you. Thank you for allowing us to
receive questions. The most important thing is that
there will finally be no people who are not
health workers or people who work
in residences or residents
of nursing homes who
People over the age of 70 are going to start receiving it.
Certainly,
when will they have to
do it? If the families can
listen to us, that they have a relative or
probably a grandmother or grandfather,
what do they have to do for it and
when?  Do you roughly estimate
that people from 65 to 69 are going to go to the next phase?
Ok,
well, Fernando, thanks for the question.
As I said before, we are going to
offer the vaccine to people 70
years of age and older in our vaccination set
that is going to be
spread out in multiple sites in the
county now along with these
vaccination sites that we mentioned
before
there are other resources to give to  light
our elderly and that resource
through local pharmacies in this case the
walgreen and smith pharmacies that have an
agreement with the state of nevada and
according to the latest information that
we received from the state these pharmacies will
begin to offer their services
as of  On January 20, the details
of how the service is going to be offered and
we do not have it at the moment,
that is something that the state is not going to
communicate as far as they have all
the details already on how to
improve the same as these  These two
pharmacies that I mentioned are going to make
it public, we have to inform them how it will
be and the most, well, the most possible is that
they from me  send
direct communication to the families in your
neighborhood that the service is available at
your local pharmacy and they can
process the service for
an elderly action there on that is an
important resource in combination with the
other to assist
vaccination centers and  Apart from that, you are
going to see
what
the trading on teams is called, which will be
made up of the small number of
health personnel who are going to offer the
vaccine
to certain specific sites, but
that type of intervention is more
related to organizations in
this case.  that work with commerce
are not certain communities and we have
numbers of elderly that are part of
that organization of that group and then
they will coordinate with the
different department of health or
through other collaborators to be able to
bring simple production to sites that
they have  they already predestine, that is,
access to the vaccine for people
aged 60 and over is going to be different  rso is not just going to
be
these large vaccination signs, it's
also going to be in local pharmacies
and they're also going to see
opportunities with small teams that are
going to work with certain
community groups that we're going to do this
service for the elderly and that's going to
getting to know as we move in this
campaign
I don't know if I answered your questions
is the scope of our laws and to
start taking is the description is
for our elders to do it
when it would be for the rest of the county
ok ok although the room asks in the
It seems that the world is related to
the city of Las Vegas that has taken
appointments to vaccinate the elderly and when it
would be added to student counties
when I think that this question has already
answered nothing
with my previous comment starting
tomorrow we are going to open the appointments
for the elderly and the
essential work group that I mentioned earlier,
that is, they will not be able to
receive vaccines at the dem sites
Vaccination assive either in our
office here and here in Decatur as
in the sampling is a and also in the
head of the city of Las Vegas its
speed of people are that where there
are 600 vaccines and in all and also
in the cashman center  that is going to start
operating on Thursday morning games
starting tomorrow are the sites that
are available to parents and the most
and from January 20 the
pharmacies of the walking and smith are going to
start offering this service
as well as  I previously said the details of
how the pharmacies will be of service,
we do not have them at the
moment, the state will notify us
about it, they are ready to
meet you
and
that news must be demonstrated by the
rector and the fan, issues of this type
of reports and you will need it for when the
radiation people
ok
ok it seems that the question is what
documentation is it to tell people
for the unemployed and the appointments well that
is what is requested is that it is that l  Does the
person have an
identification document or something that
shows us that in these personal matters that
the person says that it is that it does not have to
be the driver's license because
we know that there is a
relatively large number of people in this
community who  They are undocumented and do
not have access to a driver's license,
but any document that
the person presents that proves
that the person lives here
is sufficient for injuries, that is, it does
not become a passport nor does it have to
be a driver's license.  driving any
document that the person shows with
his name and that is enough for
us
h
donington